for this final video for this week let's
talk a bit about why convolutions are so
useful when you include them in your new
networks and then finally let's briefly
talk about how to put this all together
and how you can train a convolutional
neural network when you have a labeled
training set I think there are two main
advantages of convolutional layers over
just using fully connected layers and
the advantages are parameter sharing and
sparsity of connections let me
illustrate to an example let's say you
have a 32 by 32 by 3 dimensional image
and this actually comes from the example
from the previous video but let's say
you use a 5 by 5 filter with 6 filters
and so this gives you a 28 by 28 by 6
dimensional output so 32 by 32 by 3 is
and 20 by 20 by 60 we multiply all those
numbers in 4704 and so if you were to
create in your network with 3072 units
in one layer and you know 4704 units in
the next layer and if you were to
connect every one of these neurons then
the weight matrix the number of
parameters in the weight matrix would be
a 3072
times four thousand seven and four which
is about 14 million so that's just a lot
of parameters to train and you know
today you can train your networks with
even more parameters than 14 million but
considering that this is just a pretty
small image this is some other
parameters to train and of course if
this were to be a thousand by thousand
image then you know this weight matrix
will just become infeasible large
if you look at the number of parameters
in this convolutional layer each filter
is five by five so each filter has 25
parameters plus a bias parameter a means
you have 26 parameters per filter and
you have six filters so the total number
of parameters is that which is equal 256
parameters and so the number of
parameters in this complains quite small
and the reason that a confident has run
through these small parameters is really
two reasons one is parameter sharing and
then parameter sharing is motivated by
the observation that a feature detector
such as vertical edge detector let's use
when one how the image is produce for
another poly the image and what that
means is that if you think about say a
three by three filter for detecting
vertical edges you can then apply the
same three by three filter over here and
in the next position over and the next
position over and so on and so each of
these you know feature detectors each of
these outputs can use the same
parameters in lots of different
positions in your input image in order
to detect say a vertical edge or some
other feature and I think this is true
for low-level features like edges as
well as for higher-level features like
maybe detecting the I the indicates a
face where cats or something is there
but being with a share in this case the
same nine parameters to compute all 16
of these outputs is one of the ways the
number of parameters is reduced and it
also just seems intuitive that a feature
detector like a vertical edge detector
computed for the upper left-hand corner
of the image the same feature seems like
the world probably useful has a good
chance of being useful for the lower
right hand corner of the image so maybe
you don't need to learn separate feature
detectors for the upper left and the
lower right hand corners of the image
and maybe you do have a data set where
you know the upper left-hand corner and
in the right-hand corner have different
distributions so they maybe look a
little bit different but they might be
similar enough their share in future
detectors in all across the image
works just fine the second way that
confidence get away with having
relatively few parameters is by having
sparse connection so here's what I mean
if you look at the zero this was
computed by 3x3 convolution and so it
depends only on this V by V input grid
of cells so is as if this output unit on
the right is connected only to nine out
of these six by six 36 input features
and in particular the rest of these
pixel values you know only these pixel
values all of these pixel values do not
have any input on this do not have any
effect on that output so that's what I
mean by sponsee of connections as an
another example this output depends only
on these nine input features and so as
as if only those nine input features a
connector to this output and the other
pixels just don't affect this output at
all
and so through these two mechanisms a
new network has a lot fewer parameters
which allows it to be trained to have
smaller training sets and is less prone
to be overfitting and sometimes you also
hear about convolutional neural networks
being very good at capturing translation
invariance and that's the observation
that a picture of a cat shifted a couple
pixels to the right is still pretty
clearly a cat and convolutional
structure helps tune your network and
code the fact that an image shifted a
few pixels should result in pretty
similar features and should probably be
assigned the same other label and the
fact that you're applying the same
filter you knows all the positions of
the image both in the early layers and
in the later layers that hopes a neural
network automatically learn to be with a
more robust or to capture to better
capture this desirable property of
translation in the area
so these are maybe a couple of reasons
why convolutions or compositional net
neural networks work so well in computer
vision finally let's put it all together
and see how you can train one of these
networks let's say you want to build a
CAD detector and you have a neighbor
training set as follows where now X is a
image and the Y's can be binary labels
or one of K classes and let's say you've
chosen a convolutional neural network
structure maybe saute the image and then
having you know convolutional and
pooling layers and then some fully
connected layers followed by a soft max
output that then outputs Y hat the
conflation and the fully connected
layers will have various parameters W as
well as biases B and so any setting of
the parameters therefore lets you define
a cost function similar to what we have
seen in their previous courses where
would randomly initialize parameters W
and B you can compute the cost J as the
sum of losses of your neural networks
predictions on your entire training set
may be divided by M so to train this
neural network all you need to do is
then use gradient descents or some other
algorithm like gradient descent or
momentum or armless problem or something
else in order to optimize all the
parameters of the new network to try to
reduce the cost function J and you find
that if you do this you can build a very
effective detector or some other
detector so
graduations on finishing this week's
videos you've now seen all the basic
building blocks of a convolutional
neural network and how to put them
together into an effective image
recognition system in this week's four
exercises I think all of these things
will come more concrete and you get the
chance to practice implementing these
things yourself and seeing it work for
yourself
next week we'll continue to go deeper
into convolutional neural networks I
mentioned earlier that there's just a
lot of hyper parameters and
convolutional neural networks so what I
want to do next week is show you a few
concrete examples of some of the most
effective convolutional neural networks
so you can start to recognize the
patterns that what types of network
architectures are effective and one
thing that people often do is just take
the architecture that someone else has
found and published in the research
paper and just use that for your
application and so by seeing some more
concrete examples next week you also
learn how to do that better and beyond
that makes people also just get better
intuitions about what makes confidence
work well and then in the rest of the
course we'll also see a variety of other
computer vision applications such as
object detection and neuro style
transfer how to create new forms of
artwork using these types of algorithms
so that's it for this week best of luck
with the homeworks and I look forward to
seeing you next week